just about time for baseball we've had a
delay of some one hour and 45 minutes
but game one of the four game series is
just about ready to get underway making
your cincinnati reds debut
left-hander wade miley a 14-game winner
a season ago with houston and we'll
leave it up to wilson contreras to
catcher
first pitch is hit
fair into the left-field corner
bryant will score rizzo will stop at
third it's a double for contreras
steven souza jr in his cup debut that
ball is smashed into the corner we'll
knock in a couple more
welcome to the cubs stephen souza jr
it's three to nothing here is david
bodie let's see if david can keep the
ending going there's a base hit to right
souza around third
he will score and it's four to nothing
david ross feeling good about his lineup
tonight right he gives susa a start
gives body a start and they both cash in
early john lester last year as he always
does 30 plus starts 31 to be exact 13
and 10 with an era of 4.46
we'll bring up castellanos the ex-cub
it's a ground ball to third
loved by bodhi and lester with a shut
down first bobby
two men on you get that feeling baez is
about ready to bust out with some extra
bass knocks comes back to bios he swings
and lines went down the left field live
base hit it's going to go all the way to
the wall this will drive in bryant who
crosses the plate rizzo goes to third on
a double by baez hubs lead 5-0 schwarber
checks when the ball gets away from the
catcher and coming in to score his rizzo
over to third goes baez i'm not sure if
they got crossed up talking about the
catcher cassalli and the pitcher miley
we do know that the cubs have scored
another run and leads six to nothing
still no hits for the reds but the
inning extended and then it'll be votto
here's votto hitting a pop fly shallow
left going out as baez over near the
line makes the catch and that ends the
inning good pitch by lester one more out
to go and it's wilson contreras
came right after him with a fast ball
locked him up at 95. antoine looks good
here tonight
that's two in the third inning one away
here's aquino
hayes out looking
lester's got his first strikeout there's
cologne
and swings and sends a fly ball to left
easy play bryant still
without a hit on the reds through four
cubbies coming out here in the fifth
inning against tj antone
slow breaking ball and that one locked
up susan i don't know what he's
complaining about
two two breaking ball swing and a miss
and tj antone's just carving them up now
now four strikeouts for tj antone i mean
the reds might be down six nothing but
this is a single greatest night in the
baseball life anyway of tj anto wester
is yet to give up a hit in this one
through four and two thirds comes the
pitch by lester
this is hit in the air to left field
playable for bryant who comes in he's
under it and makes the catch
through five john lester has yet to give
up a hit cubs on top of the reds six to
nothing now rizzo
rizzo out in the deep right and it is
gone a home run his third of the year
and it's seven to nothing rizzo a
hanging breaking ball drives one over
the wall in right it's his third home
run on the young season dan wickler will
take over for john lester lester did not
give up a hit five shutout innings he
just walked the first two and
he went and he's out pitching change in
the sixth row and wick
and hitting against the grain is linker
and this will bring in a run so jesse
with a run scoring single and it's a 7-1
ball game here in the sixth inning and
they'll be at the corners
drive out into deep center almora
tracking he's on the warning track and
that'll do it first cubs lead 7-1 and
now david bode will make his way to the
plate bode lines out toward left center
it's gonna get in there
contreras
around third toward the plate and he'll
score standing it's eight to one a two
hit two rbi night from david bodie
so this will be the first big league at
bat for tyler stevenson
fly ball deep left center field and in
his first major league event tyler
stevenson plays long ball
how about that
congratulations young man go ahead and
smile indeed
luke's one into center field
and that'll bring in another run
to make it an eight to three game here
in the seventh inning bottom of the
battle
that's looped softly into right
it'll fall in a base hit
it look like uh the defender never
picked up the ball and two runs are
gonna score vado his second hit of the
game and now all of a sudden it is an
eight to five games this is a same
situation in an eight-five game and
naturally they will bring on mr kimball
they are loaded on watson the winning
run will come to the plate now this
already with a home run this season he
is all for four tonight and he's drilled
with a pitch to bring in a run
three walks in a hit batter and now all
of a sudden the tying run is in scoring
position
the winning run
is standing at first base
and now it'll be tyler stevenson
and it's ball four inside
how about that in baton played
appearance by stevenson to have that
kind of patience it's a one-run game
and david ross has got to go get his
closer now 34 pitches in this inning
brought in jeremy jefferson and philip
urban the batter here's the pitch
he struck him out that might have been
ball four
irvin went after it two down and here
comes bottle jeffress on a 3-2
bottle into center almora's got it cubs
win